normally we don't like to talk about
YouTube drama but there's something
going on right now that transcends mass
as you may know h3h3 is being sued by
another youtuber because they use his
work in one of their videos now to
everyone on the platform that seems
totally normal because the expectation
is when you put something on YouTube you
are putting it before a public forum and
if other people want to comment on that
material they have the right to do so so
long as they add something and they keep
it creative and they generally give you
credits now that's a lot different and
the way that things used to be and the
crux of the issue here is that there's a
problem with copyright law and the way
that it was written and originally
intended not only as a member of court
or digital but as a lawyer in the state
of California I think it's super
important that we take a moment to
femine not only what's before h3h3 here
but what it means for the rest of the
platform and for the future of copyright
law
[Music]
there's a lot of assumptions about what
fair use is but let's clarify what it is
and what it's not
the first thing to remember is that fair
use is not a right it's expense in order
to argue out an affirmative defense you
must present it to a fact-finder ie a
judge or jury before the court and only
under the facts of your particular case
therefore you must go through a lengthy
and costly court process in order to
assert this defense and that's exactly
why the h3h3 case is taking so long and
costing so much money when they have
their day in court the judge will look
to four factors to determine whether or
not the various defense applied number
one he will look to the purpose and
character of the youth now this one is
very important the judge will be looking
to see if whether or not when a CH three
took the video from the other youtuber
and put it in their own they added
something to that youtubers video in
this particular case they put three
minutes of another youtubers video in
between 11 minutes of their own creative
commentary but they didn't actually
touch or affect the other youtubers work
so it ultimately comes down to the judge
or jury to decide whether or not placing
someone else's video in between moments
of constructive creative comedic
commentary is in and of itself
transformative or if it's not because
they just took it and placed it and then
added some of their own separately if
h3h3 wins it will set a precedent that
says their style of video creating does
fall under the first factor of fair use
the second factor that the judge will
look at is the nature of the copyrighted
work itself and whether or not that work
is strongly copyrightable is it original
is it unique the answer is yes and this
factor actually does fall in that other
youtubers favor number three the judge
will look to the amount and
substantiality of proportion used in
relation to the copyrighted work as a
whole here h3h3 use
the entire video which traditionally is
a bad thing but just like in the music
industry where the courts had to come up
with a guideline so that musicians could
cover other musicians songs the same
thing is happening here but the law
hasn't caught up yet people online
consider it entirely fair and normal to
take someone else's video and add
something to it you look at the way that
Mike Steve has done dubstep remixes you
look at the way that h3h3 is done
comedic commentary on other people's
videos this goes on across the board and
it's considered acceptable by the
community the law hasn't caught up yet
and this is exactly where the problem
lies and number four the court will
consider the effect of the new use on
the market of the original copyrighted
works does the new use add value or take
away value from the original copyright
in this case I think h3h3 views
definitely adds value to the original
youtubers video because it gets him more
views it gets his name out there and it
overall adds value to his channel across
the class as you can see this case
ultimately comes down to two things
whether or not the court will consider
h3h3 is used to be transformative and
whether or not they will consider the
type of use that's being made across the
digital community to be fair much in the
same way that they had to recognize
musicians making covers of other
people's songs the problem is they
haven't quite caught up with this yet
and if h3h3 is able to win this case on
this fair use defense it will set
precedent for the rest of the digital
space and the rest of our community and
this is what makes this case super super
important for all of you who supported
h3h3 in this fight or even just add to
the conversation that's happening right
now thank you it's very important it's
going to mean a lot
or it's going to mean the world it's
guys it means the world does it's going
to be a lot not just for even in he'll
of it for the world
did you understand all that
it's a hard day and I'm and it's what
we're thinking about all the time
hopefully I'll find out this month if
I'll be in financial ruin for the rest
of my life or not $54,000 it's like work
bucks no matter what hat